for more live coverage of a forum on
financial services the high cost of
consumer credit a status report on
related products we heard at an earlier
panel this morning that with interest
rates so low many consumers have been
able to take advantage of an awful lot
of credit and I think someone said max
to the hilt if I'm not mistaken but
there are a large number of consumers
certainly a very large segment of our
population that has been unable to take
advantage of a low-cost credit and
unfortunately has had to turn to some
very expensive products we're going to
hear a bit about some of those today as
well as some of the alternatives that
may be available to those consumers and
joining us this afternoon and I'll
introduce them in the order in which
they're speaking first many of you know
Jeanie Anne Fox
Jean Anne is the director of consumer
protection for the Consumer Federation
of America and also serves as the vice
president of the board of directors of
consumers Union prior to joining CFA
Jean Ann was the president of the
Virginia citizens consumer Council and
other past experience includes serving
as the director of the Allegheny County
Bureau of Consumer Services and as
regional manager of the bureau of
consumer services of the Pennsylvania
Public Utility Commission and I think I
saw a recent news article recently with
or an opinion piece I shouldn't we
shouldn't call it a news article on the
ruminations of what the world would be
like if Jean Ann was President of the
United States and it wasn't particularly
I I think it was an incredibly
flattering piece if any of you have seen
it you may wanna check it out online and
then next we're gonna hear from dr.
Michael Stegman dr. Stegman is the
Duncan McCray and and Rebecca Kyle
McCray professor of public policy and
business at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill chairman also
the Department of Public Policy and
director of the Center for community
capitalism in the Kenan fleiger who by
Flagler sorry Business School Frank
Hawkins Kenan Institute a private
enterprise and I'll skip through the
very long and very distinguished
biography just to highlight a couple of
other key points in it
June 14 1997 issue the National Journal
named him one of Washington's 100 most
influential decision-makers and dr.
segment has written extensively on
housing and community development policy
and financial services for the poor and
then finally joining us this afternoon
is Ed Jacob it is the manager of the
Northside community Federal Credit Union
a thirty-year-old community development
credit union with assets of nine million
dollars the credit union is certified is
a certified community development
financial institution and has a
low-income service designation from the
National Credit Union Administration and
north side offers checking and saving
accounts ATM cards small consumer loans
Visa credit cards new and used auto
loans as well as home equity and
mortgage loans and prior to his work at
the Credit Union mr. Jacob was a
vice-president in the community
reinvestment department for bank one
corporation and with that I'll turn it
over to Jean M good afternoon I
appreciate all of you coming to this
session at CFA s Financial Services
conference I've been asked to lay out
the current market and high-cost
short-term loans that are offered to
consumers who may have less than a
perfect credit rating and the three
products that I'm going to include in my
comments this afternoon are refund
anticipation loans which are the loans
that you get at the time that you have
your taxes prepared and you're not
willing to wait until the IRS sends you
the check with your refund payday loans
which are small loans based on the
lender holding your personal check until
the next payday or holding the
electronic access to your bank account
so that the two or three or five hundred
dollars that you borrow today are paid
back on your next payday in full and
another form of high-cost short-term
lending which goes under a variety of
names car title pawn or car title loans
which are offered in some states where
instead of
in your car you pawned the piece of
paper that evidences that you owned the
car but it's treated as a pawn or a
short-term loan and consumers end up
paying very high prices for this way a
borrowing a few hundred to a thousand
dollars or so another type of credit in
this same part of the market is a
rent-to-own transaction but that is more
equivalent to financing the purchase of
goods and services rather than cash
advances so we will not I go into
rent-to-own
today although they are sure I would
make a great president of the United
States there are there are some figures
on the size of these markets but this is
not a closely tracked segment of the
credit industry the Federal Reserve does
not put out studies saying how much
consumers are are spending on payday
loans or car title pawns we we can
calculate from IRS information and the
report said the big companies a bit of
the size of the refund anticipation loan
industry but according to industry
analysts estimates the payday loan
market involves 40 billion that's
billion with a B in lending to consumers
in a year for which consumers pay six
billion dollars I don't believe that
that number includes the growing market
of internet payday lending and we really
don't know how much money is involved in
that segment although one of the
internet payday loan companies estimates
that seventy million Americans use that
service every year I'm not quite sure
how they know that but that's one of the
projections we see in the payday loan
market that some of the larger privately
held companies are starting to go public
so that there is more information
available in and filings at the
Securities and Exchange Commission but
this is an industry that's gone from
nothing to this forty billion dollar
annual volume in about ten years and the
industry projects that they're about
22,000 storefronts out
Cesar check cashers pawnshops and
standalone payday loan outlets that make
these short-term small loans to
consumers on the basis of writing a
check without money in the bank to cover
it at the time another short-term fast
cash loan that's made to folks are
refund anticipation loans these are made
by commercial tax preparers and their
partner banks and they're made to
consumers who don't have the cash in
their pocket to pay to have their taxes
prepared and therefore they borrow
against their expected refund because
the fees for preparing their their taxes
are taken out taken out of the the
expected refund about half of refund
anticipation loans Umar's are getting
the Earned Income Tax Credit which means
they are the working poor although they
only make up about 15% of all taxpayers
so this is by definition a lower-income
a group of people who are probably
having trouble making ends meet and feel
the need to get money quickly the CFA
and the National Consumer Law Center I
have put out reports on the refund
anticipation loan market for the last
several years in January and our most
recent report estimated that consumers
paid one point fourteen billion dollars
in Brawl fees plus another 406 million
in efiling or administrative fees in in
the texture 2002 and that that involved
twelve point seven million refund
anticipation loans being made which was
up from the year before so that it was a
growing market the the next form of
high-cost credit that we're going to
talk about a bit is a car titled pawn
car title loan market we have not seen
any credible estimates as to how big
that market is I've heard one reference
it's about a fourth the payday loan
business but there's not a national
trade group for it I haven't seen
in the industry study projections but we
do know that it's sizeable and that it's
growing as the companies find ways to do
business and states where there isn't
specific authorizing legislation there
was a recent hearing in Tennessee vice
Senate committee about car tidal ponds
and they heard stories about an 80 year
old woman who lost her car because she
couldn't pay back the loan that was
secured by her title to the car another
person who ended up paying $13,000 on a
one thousand dollar loan by the time
they defaulted and the way a car title
our loan or car title pond works is you
go down and you borrow a few hundred up
to a thousand or two but usually no more
than a fourth of the value of the car
that you've paid for and you have the
title - and instead of pawning the
vehicle that you would leave behind you
pawn the piece of paper that says you
own the car and some places the lender
takes a copy of a set of keys for the
car and the loan is structured like a
typical pawn transaction we're supposed
to be paid back at the end of the month
well cash-strapped consumers can't pay
back a thousand or so at the end of the
month sue end up paying the finance
charge to extend it for another period
of time and if you miss a payment they
have the keys and they come drive your
car away and they sell it and in some
cases they just keep all the money they
get for it so it's extremely high-risk
credit that is targeted at folks who may
think they have no other way to borrow
money there are some common elements for
all three types of short-term cash loans
for consumers they target cash-strapped
consumers who are having trouble making
ends meet and there's a very large
market that meets that description about
half of Americans have trouble making it
from payday to payday and are always in
need of a bit more cash another
characteristic is that these loans cost
triple digit interest rates but because
they're for such short periods of time
the dollar finance charges that are
quoted on the loans don't register with
consumers as to how relatively expensive
these are for example with a payday loan
in the in the best of circumstances
you're paying $15 per hundred so you may
not think that $15 sounds like a lot or
if you're borrowing 300 that $45 sounds
like a lot but that's three hundred and
ninety percent annual interest some
lenders charge $30 a hundred well that's
seven hundred and eighty percent annual
interest if you get the whole two weeks
to pay it back and some of these loans
are due on your next payday which may be
in less time than that
with a refund anticipation loan those
loans are paid back when the IRS direct
deposits the tax refund into the account
open in the taxpayers name at the bank
that made the loan through the tax
repair if that's a 10-day repayment
period which is not unusual then
depending on the size of your refund and
the fees that are being charged it's 70
to 700 percent annual interest and
that's not counting the efiling or
administrative fees with cart I'll pond
we've heard of cases of the cost of up
to nine hundred percent annual interest
they're always over a hundred percent
that I've ever seen and that's extremely
expensive but if you're looking at just
what it's going to cost me at the end of
the month you may not have an
appreciation of the total cost another
characteristic is that all of these
loans put an important asset at risk if
you fail to repay a payday loan they
deposit your check and it bounces in
your charge bounced check fees by both
the payday lender and your bank if you
do enough of that then you get a black
listing on the check clearing databases
that retailers look at to see if they
want to let you pay by check at the
grocery store you may lose your bank
account and be unable to open another
one because now you're listed as a
chronic bad check bouncer on the
databases at the banks consult when they
decide whether
to open an account for you if you are
getting a refund anticipation loan based
on your earned income tax credit and
your turn down for the full amount of
the tax refund you were expecting you
have to pay the bank back and you have
to pay them back pretty quickly even if
you don't get the tax refund that you
were expecting if you fail to pay a car
title pend you lose the car so all of
these types of lending put an important
asset at risk for consumers for whom
that may be one of the more valuable
things they have they're also structured
at least the payday loans and the car
title loans are structured in a way that
trap consumers in repeat borrowing it's
very difficult to pay back five hundred
dollars plus the finance charge on your
next payday if you were so hard up you
were having trouble making ends meet and
felt the need to borrow it just to get
by until your next payday
Iowa regulators tell us that the average
payday loan customer at one lender in
Iowa has over twelve loans per year and
we know that people go to more than one
payday loan outlet typically so the idea
that these are just short-term one-time
extensions of credit are not borne out
by the data these loans also are have a
common characteristic in that at least
they started off by presenting
themselves is anything other than credit
payday loan started out as slow check
cashing and some folks confused refund
anticipation loans with rapid refunds or
quick refunds from the IRS and in the
case of the car title pawn you may be
lulled into thinking that you've just
signed a piece of paper when in fact you
have signed over your vehicle and those
aren't really pawns but they were
presented as pawns to get around state
small loan law interest rate limits
another characteristic of these types of
lenders
is that they don't always do the best
job possible at living up to the
consumer protection laws that are
supposed to govern the small owner in
the credit market there has been an
ongoing battle for example at the state
legislative level about enforcing usury
laws small loan interest rate caps or
carving some of these lenders out of the
state interest rate regulations where
that still applies and even when the
state has tried to stop a form of the
this kind of lending the lenders are
very creative and finding ways around it
for example Virginia years ago took
several car title pawn companies to
court saying under our pond laws you
can't pawn a piece of paper you have to
pawn a physical product and so the car
title pawn industry went away for a
while after the Attorney General was
successful at that
but now the car title lenders are back
in Virginia and now they're claiming
this is not a pond this is now open and
credit because under the Virginia
financial code opening credit providers
don't have to be licensed and there's no
interest rate cap applied because that
part of the code was written to benefit
the credit card industry the car title
lenders have shown up in California
under the one of their credit laws not
under the pond law because they found a
little gap in the law that allows them
to do their business the implications I
think for consumers here is that
vulnerable will cash-strapped families
who can least afford to pay such high
rates and to put what they own at such
risk are the ones who are most likely to
be affected and those are the consumers
who most need effective consumer
protection laws on the books and to be
enforced and another implication is that
consumer protections need to be
constantly updated to meet the newest
variety of tactics used by the industry
this week CFA released a new report on
payday lending done
for the internet and that reports
available on our website at Consumer
Federation ders and we found that we
could only verify that 20 out of the
hundred companies were actually licensed
in a state but even then they had picked
states that had the weakest consumer
protection and restrictions on the books
and we're doing business and states
without complying with the the credit
laws or the even the payday loan laws
that applied to loans made in that state
some states are starting to take action
New York and Kansas and Colorado have
cases underway about internet payday
lenders that aren't complying with their
state consumer protections but that's
just one that there's a continuing
battle of keeping the the laws and the
enforcement up to date with industry
tactics and the last implication for all
of us is that advocates and regulators
need to be vigilant in watching the
fringe credit market to be sure that the
laws are enforced and that consumers are
protected from types of credit that put
their assets at risk that trapped them
in a perpetual cycle of borrowing and
that caused some triple digit interest
rates thank you great yes thank you let
me just begin with a kind of truth in
intro Beth the reason I was one of the
hundred most influential decision-makers
in Washington was not because of me it
was because I was assistant secretary at
HUD working with Henry Cisneros and
during the first Clinton term I am now
the hundred million most influential
this
in my current position when I left HUD
in 1997 and came back to the University
of North Carolina I started a center
called the Center for community
capitalism that focuses on ways to
attract private capital to distressed
communities help low-income people build
wealth and it started with an emphasis
on how technology can be used to help
connect people to the financial
mainstream in the unbanked an
astoundingly high percentage of the
population doesn't have a bank account
and we focused on that and then moved
into the consumer credit area because if
you're interested in wealth building you
really need to deal with issues of
wealth stripping and so the predatory
lending area and the payday area we got
into through that kind of vehicle the
reason I titled the presentation a
sampler is every slide I have here is
kind of backed up by a paper and a
project and I'm trying to boil down four
or five areas and things that I think
are very important that relate to what
this panel is about and you can download
the papers and I'll be glad to provide
you information about it we are doing we
did a statewide survey for the
Department of Social Services in North
Carolina that was concerned about
welfare to work and people that were
leaving the welfare rolls without bank
account's so they wanted to know really
what was going on in their lives and we
you know there are a lot of national
surveys the Federal Reserve does it
every three years for the country but
there are to my knowledge no state has
done a survey of the financial services
behavior of low-income families in those
states that would be available to
policymakers and and advocates and so on
and this is a we have a lot of
information about this but what we're
looking at here is compared to whites
african-american low-income African
American use of credit Latino use of
credit
paired to whites and you see really
there are distinctly different patterns
that we have to understand the
low-income african-american North
Carolina is 50% actually it's more
likely to be unbanked or 50% as likely
to have a bank account we have about
twenty seventeen percent of white under
$30,000 income families are unbanked in
North Carolina it's it's almost it's
twice that forty two percent of people
that are leaving the welfare rolls going
from welfare to work or operating the
cash economy no bank account and so on
so but if you look at this the
low-income African American bars under
$30,000 families 2.6 times more likely
to borrow from payday lenders frequently
than white families controlling for
marital status and and twice as likely
to bounce checks one and a half times
more likely to have multiple credit
problems if you switch over to the
Latino Hispanic population quite
different a higher percentage are banked
significantly lower credit card debt and
this runs through our research more
likely to pay off credit card balances
Latino then then whites and African
Americans the fringe banking kind of
sector of choice of Latinos is pawning
for African Americans it's the payday
lending more or less very distinct
different patterns and if you just look
at the likelihood of paying off for
those who are bank to have credit cards
the likelihood of paying off your credit
card debt at the end of the month if you
are a recent lever from the welfare
rolls relative to current recipients you
are one and a half times more likely not
to pay off your debt at the end of month
hardly ever or never you're carrying on
average about a $900 credit card debt
with you if you're African American
you're 1.3 times
likely as White's to not pay off your
end of month card if you are Latino with
a credit card your you are half as
likely to carry the debt over in other
words you twice would like to pay it off
Latino low income Latino a more
conservative financially in terms of
that now I don't know if that is
consistent with what you're finding the
interesting thing is we have a bank
account you know we keep talking about
strategies to get help people get bank
accounts if you have a bank account
you're six times as likely more likely
to get into trouble with debt right and
so we have really the pulls and pushes
here when people say I don't need a bank
account because I don't have enough
money for it and we say well yes you do
you do need a bank account it will save
you money from payday lenders there are
dangers without financial education that
are associated with carrying more dead
and getting financially more careless
with a bank account
we too are looking at payday lenders but
what we're looking as the business model
of payday lending in and this is at
North Carolina's work you want to just
look at two things I'll just very very
quickly the average payday loan company
at about five-and-a-half outlets in
North Carolina in 2000 about 352
customers per outlet about 6.6 percent
of the value of all of the loans the
deferred checks bounced now that's a
profit Center in part because they
recover a lot of that the average
percentage rate was 417 percent if you
annualize it and the percent of
customers who borrowed at least monthly
20 percent of the customers borrowed at
least monthly so when jeanann says it's
not a short term for a significant
minority it is a long-term loan and the
APR is a true measure of the cost not
the $15 per hundred but if you look at
the standard ie if you just look at that
first column look at two things
customers per outlet and the percent of
customer
who borrow at least monthly those are
the two most important drivers of the
cash flow of payday lenders it is a
transaction based business where street
traffic is really what is the most
important variable how many people in
the door how many transactions generally
that's the number of customers locating
in a convenient place good hours turning
it over the second most important
variable is the percent of your
customers who borrow at least monthly
that core of chronic borrowers so the
basic business model the the financial
success of the industry is based not on
short turn occasional as you see the ads
the kids need shoes for school
Christmas is coming the to week a car
repair and then I'll pay the fact of the
matter is many many families when they
get that paycheck can't give that
paycheck to the payday lender and still
meet their needs that week and so they
roll it over so the rollovers and the
renewals are the key from a public
policy standpoint in my view of dealing
with this we are doing a study of
Arielle's and and so on but I just have
here is a simple thing we are at three
voluntary income tax voluntary
preparation sites in the state we have
interviewed 150 families that went there
for their free tax preparation and
interviewing them and finding out eh
what are they going to spend their
refund on how are they going to devote
their refund and six months later were
coming back and re interviewing them to
see actually what they did do and this
evaluation is actually being supported
financially by the banking commissioner
of North Carolina because he thinks next
year if he has some banks at the Vita
sites the voluntary income tax
assistance sites he will be able to help
people get bank accounts and and help
them this is the one third of those
people that we interviewed who in 2002
used a professional tax preparer and
also got a rapid ral a rapid advance
loan the total refund that they got was
the sum of five eighty eight seventy
five and eighty seven dollars seven
hundred and twenty some odd dollars
seventy-five of that went to pay for
that rapid refund and eighty seven for
tax preparation so that's about a twenty
to twenty three percent bite out of that
refund that's a very significant
percentage that they're walking away
from so helping people prepare their
taxes making and helping them qualify
for the Earned Income Tax Credit and not
paying for those high fees is very
important we are just in the beginning
of analyzing the data from this North
Carolina is the first state with a
predatory lending law and we're doing a
lot of work evaluating the impacts of
that law because we are the first state
that passed the law on it
we have a lot of attention being paid in
North Carolina by the industry by a lot
of others saying that laws like North
Carolina's drive out drive out subprime
make it difficult for people to get
loans raise the cost of credit to people
with blemished credit because they're
chasing away lenders and reducing the
supply of cause these are the terms what
what the what the state law bans no
balloon payments for high-cost loans no
lending without consideration of
borrowers to repay all of these kinds of
things what we've done is looked a
before and after the law and compared
North Carolina with neighboring states
and the rest of the south if the law was
chasing away subprime lenders then you
would expect the interest rate increase
after the law was passed to be higher in
North Carolina than in surrounding
states you can see by that 17.3 that is
not the case the law seven quarters
after the law was passed relative to
seven quarters before the law was passed
North Carolina's interest rates did not
shoot up because lenders said we're not
gonna do business in North Carolina one
of the things the law does is it bans
extended prepayment penalties locking
people into their loans so that they
can't refinance when interest rates go
down look what happened seven quarters
after law North Carolina's subprime
refinance loans went down 75% with
prepayment penalties while you can see
what happened in the other states you go
on and on with this change in the number
of subprime refinance loans with at
least one predatory feature we saw a
reduction of more than 50% in abusive
loans in North Carolina
after the law was passed 90% of the
reduction in refinancing in the subprime
world in North Carolina after the law
was passed 90% of the reduction in the
refinance loans was in loans with
predatory terms those are the kinds of
loans you'd like to drive out of the
state so this is a very important part
of the work of the center we're doing a
lot of work on the unbanked as I said
and that little chart is very
interesting in North Carolina if you
just look at that chart what it really
says is in terms of the location of bank
branches relative to check cashers the
the greater the greater the minority
population percentage population in at
North Connick County the fewer the banks
controlling for population size and so
on and if you look at the models that
we've developed and so on for every 12
percentage point increase in the black
population of average county in North
Carolina one bank branch is lost in one
check cashing outlet is gained if you
look at the locational kind of
strategies of check caches and payday
lenders we have a very rapidly expanding
Latino population and and so for every
two percentage point increase in Latino
population we have one less Bank branch
controlling for other other
characteristics of the counties
we're doing a lot of work on the kind of
unbanked and the locational
characteristic
the Federal Reserve looks at Bank
closings looks at what has happened to
bank branches as a result of both
consolidation and overtime we know that
there's been a decline in banks and
low-income neighborhoods there's some
debate about whether that's a business
based decision the Federal Reserve study
suggests that on a per capita basis
low-income areas really haven't lost as
many bank branches as in the absolute
sense because that population is
declining in a lot of low-income
neighborhoods as we know but any event
we know there's been a decline of Bank
branches in long term neighborhoods the
question is what's happening to ATM
machines forty states are now delivering
their welfare benefits through ATMs
electronically you know a hundred
percent of the states are delivering
food stamps with a plastic swipe like a
debit card right at point of sale in
retailers the self-service technology is
becoming increasingly important there is
no database of the location of ATMs we
spent the last two years trying to
compile one and we're beginning to
analyze the spatial characteristics of
it and I just want to give you two kind
of if you look at the hundred largest
cities taken together this is a
Brookings Institution database of the
hundred largest cities where they
divided the cities into a core the
middle ring and outer rings if you look
at the ATM addresses per 10,000
population if you look at the left in
the inner ring you see 29.3 that's for
low minority census tracts under 15%
minority
you look at over 50% minority you see
13.4 there's a significant difference if
we look at the relationship between high
and low income census tracts high
low-income minority tracts we're
beginning to see if these patterns kind
of hold at different levels of of
investigation and we're looking at
different cities this is just Detroit if
you look at Central City Detroit there
really are very few census tracts in
Detroit that are 0 to 15 percent
minority it is a very heavily
african-american City as you know but if
you look at the 43.6 ATM addresses per
10,000 people in 15 to 30 percent
minority census tracts that falls to 6.7
ATM addresses in communities
neighborhoods that are 50% more minority
what we think needs to be done here is
that through the CRA we need to really
have examiner's and the financial
regulators collecting more information
on ATMs deployment strategies of ATMs
these portals are becoming increasingly
important to low-income communities all
of the work that I'm talking about today
you can find more information at our
Center for community capitalism at WWCC
conc dot e-d-u thank you
a good afternoon Jean Ann and Michael
have kind of given you the lay of the
land or what the industry looks like and
what the sort of problems were facing
and dealing with our my role is kind of
as a financial institution to talk about
possible alternatives to some of the
predatory loans that are out there and
ways to do this in a sustainable way
Beth mentioned when she introduced me
that I previously worked at bank one and
then moved to North Side credit union so
I had been working at a two hundred
eighty billion dollar financial
institution with 80,000 employees and
then came about five years ago to work
for what was then a five million dollar
credit union with about four employees
and it was quite a contrast and it kind
of came to me in a couple of ways the
first was the first week that I was
there is I recognized the fact that
every day I came in my my garbage had
not been moved at night and it was still
where I had left it the other was when I
was talking to a friend at the bank and
he said what exactly do you do there
what are you doing right now
and I said well actually right now I'm
sweeping and he said that's great he
said you're a small financial
institution but every night you take
your excess funds and you manage your
liquidity and you move them into a
higher yielding account and of course
the reality was that the vacuum cleaner
was out but he is to this day he doesn't
know that that was vacuuming sometimes
so anyway I'm gonna talk a little bit
about a product that we developed at
Northside payday alternative loan to try
and compete with some of the payday
lenders that are in our community and
then talk about some of the issues that
we faced as we rolled this out we've had
this product out for about
two-and-a-half years now and so some of
the lessons that we've learned from
rolling out this product and the
struggles we've had with it and the
successes we've had with it like a lot
of new loan products it is it is really
borne out of both our experience with
our members at the credit union but also
one member in particular who had come to
us and her sister who wasn't member
brought her to us she had been taking
out payday loans for quite a while for
about three or four months had been
continuing to roll these loans over had
borrowed about three thousand dollars
four months ago had continued to roll
them over had paid three thousand
dollars and interest and roll over fees
and had not paid down a penny a
principal on those loans and so we ran
her credit report and I think an
additional frustrating thing other than
the high charges that she had were that
none of this was showing on her credit
report none of these payment she was
making the payday lenders so not only
was she's paying high fees and charges
she wasn't building up a positive
credit history and we heard this morning
about the importance how it's gonna
impact more and more parts of our lives
your credit score and your credit report
and things like that so we decided we
would try and do something about it
Martinique's who is one of my heroes
who's from North Carolina and self help
credit union said that one of the time
one of the reasons he got involved in
kind of combating predatory mortgage
lending was when he had a call to a
mortgage lender and he was trying to get
a payoff amount and the guy didn't want
to give a payoff amount and Martin said
you know what he said you picked the
wrong fight with the wrong guy on the
wrong day and part of that is really
what drove him and cases like that over
and over again to try and do something
about that and in some ways I feel that
the story of Marisol one of our members
is what drove us to say we're gonna do
something about this we had had a
product at the credit union which a lot
of financial institutions a lot of
credit unions have a small five hundred
dollar unsecured loan kind of a credit
builder loan that's fairly typical
fairly common kind of a starter product
and we had had that since really the mid
90s at North Side but the restriction on
that was that you had to be a member for
a year which was certainly good from a
credit risk perspective you get to know
the person they've had an account with
you for a while but it obviously the one
problem is it is not an alternative to a
payday loan as much as we would like
people do not go in join a credit union
and then say you know I may need have
need for an emergency loan in the future
let me join now so that if I had that
need twelve months out I can get that
loan that doesn't happen so what we
decided we would do is we would with the
what's the mout side assistance we would
really compete with the payday lenders
on convenience which is what they offer
at a very high price obviously but it's
convenient you walk in there you can get
a loan you can walk out the door in 15
minutes and we said we're gonna try and
match them on a convenience side and do
something pretty differently on the
pricing side and so what we did is we
went out and actually got some funds to
put in a segregated loan loss reserve
fund because we knew our losses would be
higher on this product than they were
with that other loan which had you had
to be a member for a year and put some
money into a segregated loan loss
reserve funds so our examiners wouldn't
be happy or at least less unhappy I
think it's probably the way I should say
it and then went out and rolled out the
product the way it's structured is that
it is a five hundred dollar loan it's at
sixteen and a half percent and the loan
is repaid
eight over six months the reason we
structured it over as a six month loan
is as you've heard earlier the structure
of traditional payday loans really
encourages the rollover you know if
you're gonna have to pay back the entire
loan in a month often you're gonna be in
a position where you can't repay that
entire loan because you've got rent due
in a couple of weeks and so then you
just roll it over so we said what's
reasonable as far as an amount of time
that somebody could pull 40 or 50
dollars out of their paycheck each time
and then kind of not continually roll
this over and we structure it that way
and we started initially with what we're
called our employer groups we have real
strong relationships with another
employers in the neighborhood and so to
get our feet wet we said let's reach out
through the HR departments at these
employers and do it that way so what
have we learned two and a half years
later where were we at we've done about
3,000 of these loans now - about 1,000
individuals and so we've got kind of
some information as far as the profile
of the borrowers as far as the way
they've used the funds and the way the
portfolio is performed over that
two-and-a-half year period the average
credit score of the payday alternative
loan borrowers is about a 532 which for
those of you know who no credit score's
in the room know that that's pretty
tough credit that's that's pretty low
credit scores and only 10% of the
borrower's have had scores over 600 I
should mention that we don't use credit
scoring to approve the loan but we are
running credit reports for the
individual the first time they take out
our payday alternative loan to kind of
build our database and learn more about
the consumer market and the members that
we're dealing with we ask people if they
take out in a previous payday loan about
a quarter of people say they have I
think it's higher you know people are
not generally willing to admit that to
you but I think it's probably a little
bit higher than that 76% of the
borrower's had collection accounts and
they had an average of 6 collection
accounts and 10% hit hit at bankruptcy
in the last three years so it's a tough
market that we're serving with this
product Michael talked a little bit
about checking accounts 25% about a
quarter of these people had never had a
change savings or a checking account
prior to coming in the credit union so
we're reaching who we want to reach
we're clearly reaching the the same
people that the the payday loan store
across the street is reaching the use of
the funds I would love to sit here and
tell you
that in each of these cases the use of
the funds was a one-time emergency it
was that the car broke they needed to
get the car repaired to get to work once
the car got repaired they'd be back on
track the reality of the situation is is
that's not the case is that most of the
people who have taken out these loans
have ongoing cash flow issues they're
struggling from payday to payday they're
struggling it they need their check two
or three days before the next paycheck
and that that's ongoing bills its rent
payments it's school tuition it's car
expenses it's those sorts of things that
really are that are the use of the funds
here so it really at least in our case
and I think probably with traditional
payday lenders is not a one-time
emergency as far as the use of the funds
one of the frustrating things with the
product is that when we did initially
the product people would come back in
about a month and say I need another one
of these and we were kind of learning as
we went along the first six eight months
of this and we said alright we've got to
set some restrictions in place here we
finally decided you get to a year to a
year and you can't have the second one
until you've paid the first one down to
$250 and when you get the second one
we're only gonna take you back up to the
500 hours you can't get a new $500 so we
kind of structured the product in that
way also we also noticed immediately
that there was a need for financial
training and financial literacy and you
heard a little bit about that this
morning financial literacy is not
required to get the loan there are some
other alternative products out there and
other credit unions and other nonprofit
lenders who do this who say you take the
financial literacy class first again we
structure our product as much as we
could and and means we're way out on the
risk spectrum as you can tell from the
kind of borrower profile but we
structured it to say we're gonna compete
on convenience and we're gonna match him
on convenience and so we didn't require
the financial training we did offer it
and we certainly encourage people to
come in and take the classes but it was
not a requirement as far as taking me as
far as getting the loan so the the
performance of the portfolio it's been
tough and it's been tougher in the last
year really for us you know there's the
story of the person somebody jumps off
an 80 storey building and you're at the
40th floor looking out the office and
you say how's it going and the person
said well so far so good
you know and I feel like that's what
happened with the portfolio in some ways
is that you know we were doing fine for
a while and then clearly word got out
into the community hey these folks are
out there that's good
we want word to get out about us but at
the same time it's really pushed our
delinquencies our delinquencies for this
product run almost 20% 60-day
delinquencies run almost 20% that's
about five times the rest of our kind of
traditional loans that we're reaching
with our membership now the good news
about that is we're running a lot less
than the traditional payday lenders
according to this kind of data that they
filed with the state they run 60-day
delinquencies with both over 50% but of
course the difference is they got the
margins to pay for that you know we're
charging sixteen and a half percent
they're charging six seven hundred
percent something like that so there
does need to be I think some ways to
manage this portfolio and kind of manage
it and I think that as we look forward
there's a couple of changes we've
already made one change they're simple
ways to structure a type of product like
this to manage the portfolio better I
think you could require the completion
of a financial literacy class or you
could require it say if you know if
somebody is not paying you back
electronically you know our don't like
what season our losses are obviously
less if we're getting paid back if they
don't see the money if it comes out of
their paycheck before they get their
paycheck through the employer that cuts
our delinquencies and losses you could
say you want to pay us back through
payroll deduction direct deposit that's
fine if not if you want the loan you're
gonna have to take the financial
training class and you could also I
think although we I don't like doing
this is say will restrict the loan based
on if it's a true emergency on the use
of the funds but then you get into a
grey area where you're saying alright
you know there's this an emergency you
know and it's just that's a tough way to
look at it so I think whether it's a
small credit union or a large bank
offering this sort of a product I think
one of the issues is profitability if
we're trying to encourage other
financial institutions larger financial
institutions hopefully ones much larger
than I am sitting on the north side of
the city of Chicago to do this sort of
thing we've got to be able to show that
is it is sustainable or at least
profitable the reality of the numbers is
that if I make a sixteen and a half
percent five hundred dollar loan and I
get paid back in six months I make about
twenty five dollars in interest on that
loan right and there is no way I'm gonna
make money on that sort of a loan you
know people have told me you know when
you start making money with this program
when you bring it to scale are you gonna
make money with this program the reality
is if you lose a little bit of money on
each loan you know scale is not a good
thing
you don't make it up on volume right so
you can't view it on a product basis no
matter how efficient you are doing this
product even if you deliver the product
electronically and there is I think
another session this afternoon on you
know payroll cards or debit cards and
trying to tie in a credit product to
that you can squeeze your transaction
costs down but I'm not sure that you
could ever squeeze it to a point to do
it that way
I think you've got to view it on a
long-term basis you've got a view
profitability on a long-term basis on a
relationship basis we're involved in a
project called the retail financial
services initiative Ellen Seidman from
shore bank advisory services here and
they're championing the six banks and
six credit unions from around the
country all trying to figure out how to
serve low-income markets and to do that
in a sustainable in a profitable way and
one of the things we get from
participating their project is a
profitability analysis it will slice and
dice our profitability by product am i
making money on home equity loans am i
making money on auto loans am i making
money on the payday alternative loan but
it will also do that
ranking my membership my customers my
members from the most profitable to the
least profitable and I can see over time
with people who take out the payday
alternative loan are they moving into
not only better asset building products
for them which allow them to save money
but also products which I can make money
on so for example how many payday
alternative loan borrowers then get an
auto loan with me a year or two later
which is a loan that I can make some
money on and so we're tracking that sort
of information so far we've had about 77
loans to 58 payday alternative loan
graduates and 10 auto loans are included
in that and obviously those numbers of
graduates should build over time but
it's the same way a traditional
financial institution would look at a
maybe a youth account or something like
that they're not making money on the
youth account but they're assuming that
over time hopefully they'll make some
money and you're trying to cross-sell a
range of products getting a larger share
of wall and things like that there are
some other credit unions and other
financial institutions who are looking
to do things like this the National
Federation of Community Development
credit unions just last month announced
a pilot they're working with credit
unions in Louisiana California New York
Ohio and Illinois who are all developing
alternatives to payday loans
they'll have different structure they'll
have different pricing some will require
financial training credit union
Louisiana will have a program
specifically to pay off existing payday
loans and the the use of the funds will
be for that so I do think that there's
other credit unions who are certainly
interested in this sort of thing and in
trying to figure out how to do it again
in a profitable in a sustainable way
I mean we measure at Northside we
measure success obviously from our own
bottom line but we measure it from a
community perspective and for our member
perspective too we've done about 3000 of
these loans now we've saved our members
about two and a half million dollars
compared up you know payday loans
traditional terms and fees and charges
from payday loans we're a small credit
union on the north side of Chicago you
know we're nine million dollars in
assets if somebody else could take this
thing on that has more you know and
we're not the smartest people in the
world believe me if somebody else who
has some scale has some knowledge has
some technical expertise that I don't
have can take this thing on there's
other ways to crack this nut
it is a difficult issue it's difficult
in some ways more so than the kind of
predatory mortgage lending because when
you at least are looking at you know
reasonably priced home equity products
or mortgage products the size of the
loan is larger part of what the
frustration with this is the loans are
five hundred dollars or so and it's just
such a small dollar amount I mean as a
federal credit union we can't charge
over 18 percent APR so I know now in my
mind you can make money on this loan if
you charge somewhere between 16 and a
half and six hundred so I've set the
parameters for you I would ask you going
forward to figure out where in there
there is a reasonably priced product
that really does help people build
assets and build wealth and could be
done in a sustainable manner but you
don't have to charge 600 percent I know
that I just have kind of you know over
the last couple years struggled with
trying to do this at sixteen and a half
percent and it's been difficult I talked
to a guy in California who franchises
payday lending stores once in the spring
actually and he said well I've got two
models for my franchises and said I've
got a model where I know I'm gonna have
20% write-offs and I've got another
model where I know I'm only gonna have
5% write-offs
but I usually recommend to my franchises
and they usually buy the model that has
20%
because that's twice as profitable for
them reaching the market and I thought
to myself you know first of all why
would you ever have it why would you
ever knowingly go into a product that
somebody can't pay back and you had
talked about the North Carolina law
you got a there's some ability-to-repay
there and it is a fundamental difference
it's just a fundamental difference in
approaching the market to say are we
really here to help people build assets
and build wealth and keep dollars in the
community or are we here for another
reason
and that's kind of I think fundamental
the fundamental difference more
important in some ways than the interest
rate I charge and interest rate the
payday lender charges across the street
is the fundamental reason we're in
business and that's that we're trying to
keep money in our members pockets and
keep money in the community and so
that's a little bit just kind of on our
product
there's a wonderful Credit Union North
Carolina State Employees Credit Union
North Carolina Jim Plain who has a
salary advance program which is really
in some ways a similar for a similar
program and he operates they said he's a
larger credit union he's done wonderful
things with that there are other credit
unions who are trying to develop these
sorts of products so I do think there's
an opportunity here there's special
opportunity for credit unions because
credit unions are often tied to the
employer and a lot of key decisions that
people make are made in the workplace
and to the extent that you can reach out
through employers to do these sorts of
products I think you can mitigate your
risk but you can also reach people at an
important point and you can also deliver
the financial training through the
employer there's just some real
opportunities to do it through the
employer and doing something like that
and finally I think there's
opportunities for banks in this
marketplace Wells Fargo has got a sort
of a salary you know an advance product
if you've got direct deposit bank one
and chase or looking at a product like
that again they've got some scale
they've got some expertise that I
certainly don't have I think there's an
opportunity to bring mainstream
financial institutions to this market we
all realize there's got to be better
regulation but at the same time we got
to provide alternatives and so I think
that's what we need to do as far as the
credit union world as far as the banking
world is to figure out how to do that in
a sustainable way and hopefully we've at
least dropped maybe a tiny stone or
pebble under the ocean that'll create a
few ripples that other people take a
look at and the north side
we first thank our panelists not only
for their presentations but of course
for their great work to protect
consumers I think we have about 20
minutes for questions do we have a mic
oh great you can remember to identify
yourself and your organization please hi
my name is Sam from ken I'm from the
office of the controller of the currency
the OCC thanks very much for
presentations enjoy them very much my
question is given that that this
business line has a very high default
rate I'm a think you're talking about
20% you know doesn't it's not gonna take
credit scoring of the individuals coming
in to know that this is a high-risk loan
and that there's gonna be need to have
some type of risk-based pricing if
larger financial institutions are gonna
enter this enter this market what is
gonna be an acceptable you know rate of
interest an acceptable APR 2 2016 2
smark in need thanks
IPO filing for one of the larger payday
lenders and run the numbers there right
off is about 1.5 percent the state of
Colorado reports on the aggregate
business payday lenders in their state
and the right office in the single
digits once they eventually collect on
the on the loan so I sign off on the
idea that this is wildly risky lending
it's risky to consumers because they pay
roll the loans over but for the lenders
because they're holding your check or
they have electronic access to your bank
account they're doing very well this is
a very profitable business according to
the publicly traded companies and the
projections of the folks selling
franchises in this business on the
question of well what's an acceptable
annual interest rate you get at the
interest rate not only by the dollar
amount of the finance charge but by the
term of the loan and the idea that
somebody who's having trouble making the
minimum payment on their credit card
can't pay back you know six hundred and
fifty dollars next week is is ridiculous
it's a bait-and-switch loan structure so
you get at an affordable APR
by having a reasonable finance charge
and by giving consumers enough time to
pay the loan back their traditional
small loan laws in the United States and
places where we still have them
typically have a thirty six percent
annual interest rate cost student a few
years back we ran what it costs to get a
cash advance on a credit card and at
that time if you paid it back within
about three months it came out to about
36% APR that sounds high in today's
market we recognize that there's a fixed
cost of doing small loans that that
shows up in the APR but but the going
rate for the payday lenders a three
hundred ninety percent and up is just
ridiculous for people so I don't have
the magic number for you but there are
viable non check holding small loan
operations in some states under their
salary borrowing laws that are you know
sixty percent forty eight percent less
less than the going rate for payday
loans and they don't have to sell credit
insurance and car club memberships to
pad to pad the rate
on the State Employees Credit Union by
the way the North Carolina State
Employees Credit it's the second largest
in the country it's not that it's just
big it's gigantic and when Jim Blaine
started a product he had direct deposit
as a requirement so that he had a really
an efficient kind of collection
mechanism if you think about ed and in
allowing installment payments versus the
payday lender who has your check in an
automatic collection system you know
that is very efficient if you start with
all if you start with the transaction
cost that it has it's going to be very
very hard to turn a profit without
looking and taking a very long-term view
the problem that I think made mainstream
financial institutions have is it's the
reputational risk issue you're
absolutely right where is that window
that would under compete because there's
plenty of room to compete with a 647
percent APR the question is where is
that safe kind of zone that will cover
costs and provide reasonable kind of
returns and it seems to me without a
partnership of the kind of consumer
groups and the advocacy groups working
with the banks the risk to the bank of
trying to do something good and then
finding the 32 percent or the 36 percent
you know APR is viewed as a ripple often
usury and it turns out that the
community then attacks the bank for
trying to really do something reasonable
I think that risk is what concerns a lot
of lenders and it's got banks and it's
going to have to be done within a kind
of a partnership context where that
number is I don't know a lot of these
folks are maxed out on credit cards or
have lost them in the credit card APR it
really depends right I mean it's 28% but
if you default it can shoot up to
whatever but it's got to be up somewhere
around there I suspect and if it was a
cash advance that's kind of where those
numbers are but the banks are very wary
of doing this and then getting attacked
I think the other piece of it is again
just to kind of focus on the
transactional cost of delivering it so
whatever way they can't squeeze the
transaction cost allows for a more
affordable APR if they do have as Jim
does know you know you're gonna get paid
electronically from that person's
paycheck and it's gonna hit in three
days then you've got very little risk
the only risk really being ok-hee law or
she lost their job at that point but
they've if you're forgetting repaid that
way you really do squeeze it if you
deliver the product electronically
through some sort of card product you're
not spending the transaction cost of
sitting down with the individual every
time they want to take a loan out then
there's a way to kind of squeeze that
one last point one of the disappointing
things that the credit union State
Employees Credit Union found was
exponential growth when they introduced
this product and then the continued
growth was based on chronic borrowing
the same problem and now you have a
credit union that's supposed to be
serving its the interests of its members
and it puts them in this kind of moral
dilemma they introduced the product to
really help people break that cycle and
they found that cycle that they were
kind of feeding the cycle and they
couldn't require they had a telephone
counselling program voluntary I mean you
get into that issue financial education
is very important how do you stop people
from hurting themselves
I was just curious how you handled
reporting we talked earlier or someone
mentioned that payday lenders typically
don't report so someone's not building
credit and then if you were reporting
were you seeing some consumers who were
able to take other kinds of lines of
credit out that might have been more
stable or a move toward purchasing a
house for example should have said I'm
with Freddie Mac Susan stocks yeah
yeah it's actually been interesting to
us um because about 5% of the borrowers
had no score when they came in no credit
history at all and so it's fascinating
to me it's fat you know it's just
fascinating I have a file which is
called credit scores I don't understand
and it's just it's increasingly thick
because someone who maybe comes in with
no credit history at all takes out this
loan may come back in six months and
apply I'm not running another credit
report if they're just getting a payday
alternative loan I don't want they have
the inquiry said but if they're coming
in for a larger loan I'll run the
quarter board and they may have like a
700 credit score based solely based on
only my loan now I'm all in favor of the
credit bureaus you know placing more
importance on loans to me in somebody's
credit score in other words if they pay
me back they get higher points for that
but I don't I don't know that that's how
fair Isaac is doing it I'm not sure that
I have the clout to deliver that I know
I'm paying higher prices for my credit
reports than I heard about this morning
somebody said it's under an hour and I
know I'm paying over $1 for a credit
reports but it's interesting to me in
the absence of no bad information they
do build up a positive score rather
quickly we do report to the credit
bureau so and we'll tell that people and
when they come in this is an opportunity
for you / - you got no credit history
this is an opportunity for you to build
credit it's gonna impact every aspect of
your life if people have a pretty
checkered credit history and a lot of
problems my little $500 loan is really
not gonna help them and it's gonna be
you know they'll get some ones on their
credit report which is something that's
positive but as far as raising the score
you know it's not something that's gonna
be that helpful but for somebody who has
very little credit it's surprising to me
how you know how it can impact
positively impact on another aspect of
that the Fair Isaac expansion score is
being described as including some of
these more fringe types of financial
products including payday lending and
it's my understanding
they use information from sort of an
intermediary so I'm assuming that that
is teletrac but I don't know that for a
fact and the interesting thing is that a
lot of consumers when they take out a
payday loan are told we don't get a
credit report that this is sort of
flying under the radar well if in fact
your experience with payday loans is
showing up on credit scoring credit
credit reports that needs to be
communicated to consumers and we don't
know whether this is a helpful thing or
not helpful thing we don't know how they
factor in whether this is a legitimate
payback on a loan that showed you
successfully handle credit or whether
this is just watching the loan flipping
going on so there's there's more to be
known about this but the idea that
there's no credit reporting may be
changing and I'm just wondering give the
impression that your borrowers are still
going to the classic payday lenders
while they're paying off your loans I
mean are you guys talking to your folks
about that at all my sense is that some
of them are still going to the payday
lenders even after they've taken out our
payday alternative loan that they are
still then a month later when I'm not
I'm not willing to make them another
loan at that point because they haven't
paid mine down halfway that they
probably are going across the street
it's the issue that Michael just
mentioned again Jim Blane is facing in
North Carolina am I just enabling people
am I really helping them fall the solve
a kind of a fundamental structural issue
and their financial management and
they're in their debt structure or am I
just kind of just am I no different than
the guys lost the stream and I'm just
that they view me and so it's
frustrating but I do I do think that I'm
certain the number of them are still
going across the street and go into the
payday lender also you know we can in
the financial training you can you know
you can put you there's you know we do
for a lot of financial training at the
credit union and I think for a lot of
people you know they do use that
opportunity use this opportunity of this
loan to kind of take advantage of that
and actually change some habits for some
other folks I'm sure they're going back
over there
following up on what you just said about
the financial training have you done any
studies that really show that there is a
relationship between having the
education and changing your habits you
know there's I'll take you shot it and
then you guys could maybe but there's
two ways to kind of measure success in
the financial training the first one
which is the easy one which doesn't tell
you the answer to your question is kind
of do they know more after the financial
training is over people know more and
they understand more after our financial
training that's step one the question
then is do they actually implement it
what I think we will probably try and do
in the future is track and I've got an
AmeriCorps VISTA with us now who can
spend some time on this sort of thing as
people who've completed the training
come in and come in for larger loans can
I see a difference in their in other
words have their credit scores which is
I guess the only empirical way I'm
thinking of measuring this and do they
have an improvement of the credit scores
compared to kind of our average member
who's coming in and borrowing and maybe
taking out a payday alternative loan and
taking out another one later can I see
that they've actually had some
improvement over the course of time I
don't expect to see that in six or nine
months but over the course of the time
can I see that maybe I think people
who've taken training have been able to
increase their average credit scores and
that I think would be one empirical way
to take a look at there's another aspect
of this Judy just emphasizing
financial literacy and better education
is is I mean it's not blame the victim
but it is it's not all of the solution
we have had usury laws and interest rate
caps for centuries in civilized
countries where there has been some
outer limit on what the financial market
can charge because we have long
recognized that there are a lot of
consumers who don't have enough leverage
enough clout in the market to demand a
reasonable price for credit anybody
who's willing to write a check when they
do not have money in the bank and pay
triple digit interest in hopes that on
their next payday they can afford to pay
that back and keep food on the table
does not have market power and with all
of our effort at finding
suitable alternatives and educating
consumers and having financial literacy
we must have effective consumer
protections on the books that are being
enforced competition does not discipline
this market adequately to protect
vulnerable borrowers point about that I
mean North Carolina had its payday
lending law sunset so we are now a wild
frontier where payday lending is illegal
but because of the bank partnerships
that payday lenders have with national
banks that can't be regulated at the
state level we have a lot of payday
lending going on but the banking
commissioner does not have any authority
to collect information to do anything at
all why when we sunset the payday
lending law over a five year period
could we not really extend it with
appropriate changes in regulations based
on what we learned the advocates really
think that in the most extreme case
think that this is a business that is
immoral and ought to be shut down others
think it's a business and the credit
will go the seekers of credit will go
underground they'll find it if they need
it in an unregulated environment and
that there are reasonable reforms that
can kind of legalize it and make it more
transparent and available these two
sides could not get together and so the
law was allowed to expire and I think
from a public policy standpoint and
quite frankly from a consumer standpoint
we are the worst for it so I think that
there really needs to be a regulatory
environment that allows this kind of
crisis credit industry to exist but
under a regulatory regime that is
reasonable I mean that's my personal
view and
we're seeing all over the country this
kind of debate going on to it the only
banks that are currently renting their
charters to help payday lenders evade
state usury and interest rates are 11
state chartered fdic-supervised banks
the Comptroller the office of Thrift
Supervision and the Federal Reserve have
not permitted their banks to do this
it's only the the state chartered FDIC
insured banks and the North Carolina
banking commissioner is investigating
one of these Renta Bank arrangements in
their state and there's private
litigation going on in North Carolina of
a but Professor Stegman is correct that
it's been one of the efforts to evade
state protection is to partner partner
with banks of some states such as
Georgia
and Maryland have have put their foot
down about it but that's part of my my
request that would be ever vigilant of
all of the ways that creative people
find to get around laws intended to
protect consumers educating consumers
piece of it I would challenge anybody to
go back to your state or if you're from
here and call a payday lender over the
phone and ask them simple questions
about how it works and I would be
shocked if any if you got a straight
answer so even if you are an educated
consumer who want to know what you're
getting yourself into you're not gonna
get that answer over the phone that
their goal is to get you in the store
and pressure you and then ultimately
suck consumers into a cycle of debt that
they cannot get out of and with that
we're out of time so again thank thank
you all for all of your your great work
we'll come back for more live coverage
of the next Consumer Federation of
America panel in about 15 minutes this
afternoon president and mrs. Bush light
the nation'